un balai d'engin pour un chantier
d'envergure depuis février 2023 les
travaux de la future gare Saint-Quentin
est ont débuté à guillencour une
cinquantaine d'ouvriers travaillent sur
cette construction ce site fait partie
des 10 stations de métro bientôt
desservies par la ligne 18 du Grand
Paris Express 35 km de voie entre
l'aéroport d'Orly et versailleschantier
on prévoit 30000 voyageurs par jour dans
cette gare euh la gare de 5 an c'est ça
va être une ouverture vers vers les les
pôles économiques et de recherche de du
plateau de sa clé et aussi vers les
pôles d'échange et d'intermodalité ici
on est sur les travaux de terrassement
de du la future boî de gare plus de 150
pie ont été plantés pour maintenir la
structure bétonnée un niveau de terre
progressivement abaissé jusqu'à bientôt
atteindre la hauteur des futures rames à
15 m sous le sol dès l'été 2024 un
tunnelier entrera en piste pour façonner
le tronçon vers la réversé chantier une
fois que le creusement du tunnel est
terminé à l'horizon 2027 on peut
envisager l'installation de de de
l'entreprise qui va réaliser l'émergence
principale et l'émergenence secondaire
de la gare on pourrait retrouver des
commerces de proximité des kiosques de
l'achat de ticket un site implanté à
proximité immédiate du Technocentre
Renault et ses 10000 salariés en
parallèle se développera autour de la
future gare le quartier des savoirs 2000
logements et 3000 m² de boutiques une
forte zone d'activité pour cette station
où sera prévu un train toutes les 90
secondes en heure de pointe ce sont des
lignes qui sont automatiques euh qui ont
des postes de commandement centralisés
dans leur centre d'exploitation ou
déportter dans des gares euh ici le
poste de commandement centralisé il est
situé à palzo la mise en service d'un
premier tronçon entre la ville de Massie
et le plateau de sacelet est prévu dès
2026 pour la gare 51 est-ce il faudra
patienter jusqu'à 2030 avec l'ouverture
complète de la ligne 18